[Music]
soldiers
that she was meant for
[Music]
what happened
my wife she's alive
what's holding the captive somewhere and
right now
we're in a little bit of trouble
are you [ __ ] with us
listen this is a [ __ ] mess
we're the most vulnerable ads in the
country
we've got soup terrorists
we got no superheroes
hi i'm stormfront who i'm the new girl
wonderful
oh god so what's your big plan
don't take that
of course we're in we blow it
super up will come
for all we know these maniacs could be
waiting for their chance to kill us
all who the
[ __ ] are you i'm just trying to help
really how with an army
of supermen millions strong
no don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ]
tits i need more soup
we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do
oh great cool totally
we just need to keep our [ __ ] together
longer all right hands in the air like
you just don't care
kill
welcome back everyone it's charlie big
surprise the boys dropped a season three
teaser for jensen ackle's character
he dropped a video this morning
announcing that he's going to be playing
the original
soldier boy during the boys season 3.
he's a big parody of captain america the
first avenger from the marvel movies in
the comics
the boy's official accounts confirmed
the news after so i'll explain
what's going on with his character and
i'll talk about the other big marvel
easter egg that we just got
sean ashmore from the x-men movies who
played iceman is going to be playing
lamplighter during season two we know
more about what's going on with his
story so i'll explain the jensen ackles
stuff first then i'll talk about
lamplighter
if you're wondering why jensen ackles is
coming to the boys the showrunner on the
boys
also ran supernatural for a while so
that's the connection
jeffrey dean morgan who played his
father on supernatural and has been in a
bunch of other big comic book movies
is going to be starring during season 3
as well as a mystery character they
haven't revealed yet
we already have bobby from supernatural
in that opening scene from season 2
talking to giancarlo esposito so there's
just a lot of supernatural people
coming to the boys the message that the
showrunner tweeted out so that he'd be
playing the original superhero and make
some jokes about his sole purpose in
life being to create new jobs for jensen
ackles but that just implies that he's
gonna be playing the original
version of soldier boy captain america
we also have some pictures of him
from the set of season two so there'll
be some soldier boy stuff happening
during season two if you're a big boys
comic book fan
the boys series changes a lot about the
comic book backstories of the characters
so i'll try to explain how they might be
changing his comic book backstory
because they're kind of combining some
things from a couple different
characters
the new version of stormfront played by
aya cash during season two
is just the latest example that big
changes to her backstory from the comics
completely different character so i'll
try to explain as we go along
because it sounds like they're giving
some of the stormfront comic book
backstory to jensen ackle's character
but this picture of the monument is of
jensen ackle's character from the boys
season two this scene is from that big
rally moment that homelander and
stormfront are having from the trailer
with the seven and all the protesters
this is early in the season when they're
still trying to drum up support for
their plan to get superheroes in the
military and you have homelander going a
little bit nuts it seems like he lasers
some of these soldiers in front he's
just going to be lasering everybody left
and right during season 2.
the monument of jensen apple's character
makes it seem like he's dressed in world
war ii gear i don't know what kind of
gun he's holding here
but you can see some of the comic booky
parts of his costume like he has the
radiation symbol belt buckle
in the comics there are a couple
different versions of the character
there's one from world war
ii from a long time ago and then there's
another version of soldier boy in
present day that gets involved in the
hero gasm in a bunch of really wtf crazy
stuff
both of them have really wtf crazy
backstories it's just the one in present
day
is way crazier than the one in the past
but the version of the character that
jensen ackles is playing from way way
back in world war
ii is just like the modern superheroes
so one of the big themes of the boys if
you haven't noticed already
is that all the people who have been
given powers through compound v
by vaude american are actually really
terrible at being superheroes
most of them don't know how to use their
abilities most of them don't know how to
work on a team together
they make that huge joke about
collateral damage during the opening
scene from season two episode one
i'll add a link for that video at the
end of this but it's basically them
talking about
thirty percent collateral damage to any
city that superheroes vot
sends it's the exact same situation with
jensen ackel's character back during
world war
ii they create him to be the superhero
as part of their version of the captain
america super soldier program sort of a
prototype for modern day
bought american superheroes but he's a
terrible superhero he doesn't know how
to use his super powers
and he leads a team during world war ii
called quote-unquote the avenging squad
guess what that's a parody of
technically even though it sounds like
it's meant to be marvel avengers
obviously
it's also kind of inspired by captain
america's invaders team that he had
during world war
ii but soldier boy as you can guess was
part of some of the earliest experiments
the united states had
trying to create their own version of a
superhero so you were talking about
captain america first avenger easter
eggs here
but way back during world war ii soldier
boy was so
incompetent as a soldier that he got his
whole team killed
one of his squad mates that managed to
survive was mallory
that's actually played by this woman on
the tv show so just a couple comic book
changes here
in the original story what happened
though is that soldier boy lay half dead
screaming for help malory sees him and
hates him so much for being so
incompetent in getting all of their
buddies killed
that he himself kills him with a grenade
and then goes on to create the boys with
butcher later
i know i said that iceman from the x-men
movies is going to be playing
lamplighter during season two
there's actually a connection between
mallory and lamplighter in butcher that
i'll explain in a second too
what the tv show is probably going to do
with jensen echols character though is
they're just going to say that he's the
original prototype
for homelanders i can't wait to see what
they do with jensen ackles i'm assuming
most of his scenes will probably be
flashbacks or there'll be newsreel
footage or something like that
moving into x-men iceman lamplighter
territory so they just announced sean
ashmore most of you know him as iceman
from the x-men movies is going to be
playing lamplighter
he actually joked about not being done
playing comic book superheroes
now he's going to be in the season 2
episodes jensen ackles won't show up to
the season 3 episodes
if you remember season 1 lamplighter
actually used to be a member of the
seven he was kicked out before the
events of season one
remember when starlight joined the seven
in the first few episodes of season one
she was actually replacing lamplighter
on the team it was all part of a big
vaude american conspiracy
the cover story that they put out was
that lamplighter was quote unquote
retiring
what actually happened is is the
lamplighter found out that mallory
this woman here was coming for the seven
investigating them so in order to
protect the team
lamplighter goes rogue burns and kills
all of her grandchildren it's super
crazy wtf
and it was such a huge cover-up that
vaught's only way to avoid
open retaliation from the u.s government
was to
vanish lamplighter from public view so
they cast him aside
and that's when mallory helps butcher
found the boys on the tv show
so that's the connection between all the
characters and sean ashmore's
lamplighter actually does have some
scenes in the season 2 trailer
so there's a picture of him here that
they tweeted out with the lighter this
is inside the sevens main meeting room
because you can see the big mural behind
them
in the season two trailer footage you
see this giant fireball explosion
in this room during a big fight scene
that's what this is from
some huge fight scene where it seems
like maybe lamplighter is helping the
boys out
because you also see starlight over here
in the middle of this knockdown drag out
fight with black noir like you see him
pounding her head into the table and
then she blasts him up into the ceiling
with her abilities
so maybe butcher has been able to turn
lamplighter against the seven and use
his abilities to try and infiltrate
vaude
i will be doing episode videos for all
the boys episodes in season two as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see those when they
post
that will all start at september 4th in
a couple weeks everyone click here for
that brand new boys season 2 trailer and
click here for my new video on the
batman 2021 movie and all the dc fandom
trailers and panels that are coming up
this weekend
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you